this Big Show with e is all these big
names
this one looks like a tortellini but we
uh Christ we shot the pilot and it was
the first I just got to LA and I was
like I did all these auditions they're
like you're you're part of the castle oh
this is insane man Joan River's
daughter's name Melissa Melissa Melissa
was the that was the main one there's
like a bunch of big names on Melissa
McCarthy was on a bunch of people I'm
the only guy and I get the job I'm like
oh hey shoot the pilot I'm like damn it
this would be great and Melissa's like
you're gonna be a star bro I'm like dude
I'm going sizzling that time I just
retired from fighting in my head I knew
if it got signed or whatever 20 episodes
I was like I'm buying a Ferrari it's
gonna be crazy so I'm waiting waiting I
keep calling my agent like this
low-level agent at the time calling
harassment dude it takes a while
Hollywood doesn't work like it takes a
while like all right three months goes
by finally he goes call me text me call
me like oh this is it there's a good
news and bad news man all right he's
like bad news this Show's not happening
I'm like what he's like yeah they decide
to go with something else but they might
come back around to him it's not
happening for a while I'm like oh man he
goes good news is you ever seen that
show botched like with those doctors
he's like yeah man they're fans they
want to fix your ears for free